هذه المصافحه التي جرت بين الرئيسين
المصري والتركي بالامس ربما تحدث نقله في
علاقات بدت مجمده وان كانت هناك محاولات
بدات قبل نحو عام بلقاءات على مستوى
مسؤولين كبار في وزاره الخارجيه في
البلدين في لقاءات من اجل البحث في تطوير
العلاقات كان هناك مطالب مصريات همم تتعلق
بمعارضين المصريين الموجودين في تركيا كان
هناك استجابه من الجانب التركي بغلق
القنوات التي تبث من الاراضي التركيه
بالنسبه لهؤلاء هناك مطالب مصريه اخرى همم
كان من بينها تسليم بعض المحكوم عليهم في
قضايا في مصر همم ولكن حتى الان لم توجد
استجابه من الجانب التركي لهذه المطالبه
ربما هذا مجمد العلاقات ما بين ال- همم
طرفين همم التي بدات اكثر من عام كان هناك
معلومات على انه سيتم جدول لقاءات همم
قريبه ولكن هذا الاختراق الذي جرى يرى
مراقبون انه تم الاعداد له منذ فتره بحيث
تجارات هذه المصافحه بشكل همم مباشر
الجانب التركي كان فيه مراحل مختلفه قد
اعلن ان المصالح وسياسه لا تعرف العداء
وانه مصر دوله مهمه وان تركيا ترغب في همم
همم
اعاده العلاقات مع مصر ان تتحدث باسم
الخارجيه المصريه قال همم ان همم رئيسيين
تطرقها الى العلاقات التاريخيه ما بين
البلدين والتفقه على تطوير العلاقات
الثنائيه وبالتالي ربما يحدث تسارع في هذا
الملف الذي بدا انه مجمدا منذ فتره ولكن
مصر بالتاكيد ستنتظر اجابه على همم
الطلبات التي طلباتها من
الاجانب همم التركي وربما نجد لقاءات
سريعه في الفتره المقبله
تامر عز الدين من القاهره شكرا لك